remember this every time you come out  here you must get this all the time but  it doesn't always come across in movies  and TV exactly how tall you are you are  quite tall yes and and people cannot  know that and I I found out today  you hold the distinction of being at six  feet four inches deep six feet five I'm  sorry whoa  crappity but anyway you were at six five  you the tallest actor to win an Oscar  that's that's why I'm grateful that you  haven't played Hamlet you're taller than  me so I'll be there with the hair that's  true with the hair yeah I know I think  we're both grateful that Shaquille  O'Neal never got an awesome yes the  great role Kazaam yeah the one you know  the one he was a rapping genie look it  up yeah there he is  [Applause]